all right thanks everyone for being here
and thanks everyone for uh being here
virtually uh so welcome to the July
Meetup it's already July so we're very
excited we have a bunch of things we're
going to get started on but first off
the first question we always ask it's
easier for people in the room but people
virtual will do it too is anyone hiring
if you're in the room raise your hand if
you're virtual go to the NY hack our
slack and post it in the job postings
channel is anyone physically here hiring
all right no one is hiring so I'm always
looking for full-time and part-time
account Executives data scientists Linux
admins shiny developers so come find me
landeranalytics.com careers let me know
if anyone I'm looking to hire if anyone
else is hiring who's not in the room go
on to like I said the slack you find the
slack at nyhacker.org and you can find
the slack this little like hashtag
button click on that and find the job
postings Channel
all right so that's the first thing
second thing we always do with the
Meetup is the pizza
this is the first time we've ever
ordered from zillions so everyone in the
room got on your phone dear Rob already
knows what to do go to bit dot lead
slash Pizza pull all lowercase and rate
the pizza we have a scale of one to five
essentially we've been rating this pizza
for almost 10 years not dispute all the
different beats for 10 years if you go
to
nyackgar.nyhackgar.org you can actually
find the data set you can find it right
now it's an interactive bar chart but
there's actually a live feed of the data
available as Json if anyone wants to
ever analyze it I highly encourage you
to analyze it so go ahead and vote and
people who are virtual let us know what
foods you're eating if you're in uh
either the zoo oh sorry you're going
slack and go to the monthly events
Meetup monthly Meetup chat I think it's
called the monthly Meetup chat go there
tell us what food you're eating
hopefully pizza or if you're better off
at YouTube go to the YouTube there's a
live chat there let us know what you're
eating you can tell there's a big part
of our Meetup
for those of you physically in the room
after the Meetup we're going to go to
Beer Authority across the street just
come and have a fun time with us we're
going to be going there afterwards it's
right across the street one of these
streets I'm not sure which way I'm
facing a couple of us Folks at home
crack open one at home with your loved
ones
um unfortunately you can't join us for
that part virtually my folks are here
we'll be going afterwards and I'll
remind you
go I want to thank Microsoft for hosting
us here they've been hosting us for a
few months and they're going to host us
for the next few months so thank you
very much I know for Microsoft's
actually in the room so hopefully
someday they know I appreciate them
next week we are very very excited for
the New York R conference
I'm very excited that we have workshops
Tuesday Wednesday in the conference
Wednesday Thursday and Friday who in the
room is going
and some of you I saw another person all
right cool
um and virtually if you're going to the
conference let us know in the in the
channel we're very excited about this if
you want to learn more if you don't know
about the conference go to rstats.ai nyr
and we'll post these links to monthly
Meetup chat into the YouTube chat
rstats.ai Mir and go and if you remember
the Meetup which you are since you're
here
the conference started out as an
extension of the Meetup so if you use
code NY hack R you get a discount code
for 20 off so hopefully you'll see some
of you folks there some of you might not
have heard of it some of you I know
already have ticket right oh come to
hope to see you there it's going to be a
really good time it's really a lot of
fun
um like I said we have speakers we have
workshops oh and we'll be giving away a
ticket after drap's talk we're gonna
give a ticket to someone in the room and
to someone virtually a free ticket to
you to those people to come attend so
don't buy it until two hours from now
all right maybe you'll win it
and I want to thank our conference
sponsors uh you know posit supporting us
they are Consortium uh Columbia
University the staff department and we
got a lot of books from book publishers
like Springer Pearson CRC press and
Manning
um so it'd be a really fun time hope a
lot of people show up
in August there's a conference d4con
taking place it's like a general purpose
data design Discovery conference has
sort of like a government sports and
entertainment theme it's a weird
combination of themes but if you want to
learn more about that
d4con.io and again the discount code NY
hack R works for you there
then
if the New York art conference was an
extension of the Meetup the our
government conference was an extension
of the New York R conference that's
taken place in October I never remember
the days like October 20 something
um there you go she does what she's
doing yes so we have workshops and
Conference and this is all in government
that means federal state local
International governments but also means
public sector ngos schools so if you're
interested in those fields if you're
somewhere in like the public sphere in
any sort you'll want to go to rstats.ai
gov and again your discount code and my
hack R works for anything we do here
right so check that out
we have the August speaker lined up but
we'll announce that like after next week
all right and I'll be here at Microsoft
September we have the venue lined up but
we think we have the speaker we'll
announce that in August Beyond August
and September if you have a company that
would like to host us physically in your
office let us know
if you would like to speak let us know
if you want to voluntold one of your
friends let us know that's the way a lot
of this stuff gets done people just get
offered up to do it
so please host us the key takeaways vote
on your pizza
post jobs the job postings Channel come
to the Beer Authority afterwards and
come to the conference and come to the
next meetups
cool
all right so with that I want to
introduce a personal friend but also a
repeat speaker both at the Meetup and at
the conference and at the argov
conference and a prolific open source
contributor an author a father a husband
any other things I should say
all right so everyone please give a warm
welcome to drock come on up here
[Applause]
hi everyone it's great to be here again
so if you're wondering what I'm going to
be talking about today so am I today
we're going to be doing um improv data
analysis so we're going to be doing it
now set a topic uh and a data set that I
haven't seen before so uh we've got
screens behind me up there there's one a
copy of being Live cast there's also a
screen up there if you're having a hard
a hard time scene back there there's one
seat up here that's gonna get a better
view please uh don't be shy to uh to
come uh grab that anytime so the way
we're going to do this is based on data
from the taiji Tuesday project tidy
Tuesday is an amazing um weekly uh date
approach run by the r for data science
online learning community and every week
they come out with the data set uh that
has been clean and processed a little
bit uh but it's there's a chance like to
try a lot of data analysis methods on so
I've uh in the last couple of years
slain I've done is is sometimes run um
screencasts where I open one of these
data sets and analyze it while people uh
streaming online give us suggestions and
ideas and I really uh enjoy that there's
a third time Jared's given me the
opportunity to do that in person so the
way we're going to do this is uh I don't
think I've done any of the data sets yet
this year but I think I'm uh they
sometimes repeat data set so I might
need an extra number or two there are 27
data sets this year I need someone in
the room to shout out a number between 1
and 27.
eight
let's get a set we're gonna I'm gonna
aim for two options it's gonna be
somebody give a another number 17
. 17 and a backup in case I uh in case I
already had looked at one of the data
sets
two
all right
so let's see what week number eight is
it's Bob Bob Ross paintings I did do and
I love the Bob Ross data said I didn't
announce that a couple years ago is it
the same let me see if it's the same um
oh colors okay that's interesting I
never I didn't the last time I did this
data set it doesn't have it didn't have
colors in it but uh it did have season
episode
and you know it's not a lot in common
because that other data set was looking
at um
at objects that were in the paintings
but all right so there's one uh but yeah
one is Bob Ross second is number 17
which is the London Marathon that's a
that's a fun idea for it uh data set
which is the um so uh anyone here run a
marathon New York somewhere else
I run a New York in 2014 and and uh
Chicago 2015. definitely never run the
London Marathon uh it's just having kids
that really haven't run anywhere except
to the you know diaper changing table
but uh yeah all right so we have London
marathon and let's throw in the third
one bird feeder watch oh man all right
hold on this is 30 what does it say
bird feeder watch on November April
survey of birds that visit backyards and
let's see so uh
huh
all right so we have three uh
that's uh interesting so we have we that
data set would include oh wow a lot of
pieces of information about
is it what birds are seeing or just how
many birds are seen bird species of
observed sort of six letter species
codes cool so we have let's go with
those three options so the three options
we have are
Bob Ross paintings for those who don't
know Bob Ross was a um an artist who
painted a little like like we're doing
here doing um uh paintings on the spot
and showing them on on uh PBS it was
really um a lovely show 17 was London
Marathon
and third is the um third option is bird
feeders
so you can only vote for one who's
voting for Bob Ross
one two three four five six seven uh
anyone for Marathon
and for bird feeders
Bob Ross it is
so we're gonna um pull the uh the data
set all right
here we go
so the great thing about this data is we
um we uh basically just copy and here we
go
this line of code I'm I'm gonna see I'm
gonna load in my packages with Thai
diverse uh usually like scales package
and uh read in our data
all right we have um
403 observations so I guess that means
403 paintings uh and let's start by
looking at what we have uh
to look at all right oh we got images
and that means we could do
visualizations with these images so
already I'm just taking a look at um uh
sorting it's looks like okay we have one
row per painting
uh we have seasons
episodes the number of colors used
a link to the video I don't have
anything I can do with with that
a list of the Colors oh so we have a few
different formats one is we have a list
of the colors used here
a list of the
color hex codes is completely different
than the last data set I work with so
that's pretty cool and then we have it
looks like a wide format one row for
each uh sorry one column for each of the
colors used
show of hands who's excited about what
we're going to do with this data
me too all right so the first thing that
I um I'm probably going to do let me see
is is tie to this data a little bit so
the columns that I care about here I
care about the um painting uh sharp pain
index why not I don't even know if I
care about the paint index doesn't look
like it was in order uh the season the
episode The numb colors and let's get
the colors and the colors hex
column color
the colors and color hacks all right so
each of these is a Json array what's up
you are your um
where people don't see your IDE they see
your website who's uh the rich people on
live streaming all right one sec
so who here has been using R for more
than five years
who's been using R for more than 10
years
all right I'm out at 11. no sorry 12. uh
I'm trying to do the math oh let's see
yeah 15 years you need to open R to do
the math yeah yeah yeah oh good ah all
right we're back we're back so we have
two columns here color and color um hex
so these are Json columns so um this is
a format for serializing uh data we're
going to want to use the Json Lite
package I'm not going to load it because
it um it uh collabors a couple of
um functions what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say colors uh Json light from
Jason and do the same
two color hex
what this is going to do is turn these
up it does not like oh um oh they're
with a single string okay what I'm going
to do is create a function called a
parse list
uh we'll take X and we'll string the
trouble is that Jason expects double
quotes
and this has single quotes so we're
going to need
go map I
harsh list
still doesn't like it um we were trying
to file oh a string replace all
here we go so now we have two columns
colors and color hex and the um and they
they're each uh list so we can see oh
yeah there's eight in this first
painting uh nine in this next painting
Etc uh if we look at the uh the data set
again did I miss any columns I got title
I got all the colors I got you um oh and
I might want image source I forgot about
that one the um
uh all right so I'm going to call this
Bob Ross tidied
and the most interesting thing we can do
with the colors is unnest them that is
uh turn them into color and color hex
turn them uh
where now we actually have one and we
used to have one row per painting now we
have one row per color per painting so
we could say okay A Walk in the woods is
no longer one color it's eight and uh
now we can start asking things like what
are the most common colors in Bob Ross
paintings so I'm going to call this Bob
Ross I'm going to call it long because
it's like a long uh format one row per
color I don't like that name I'm going
to call it Bob Ross colors one row per
color all right so let's do another
thing let me rename that column colors
the color because it's now just one at a
time
all right our first visualization so we
can see okay color is um
uh the most common color titanium white
we have some ones like midnight black
the
there's a painter in the room do you
know this word does anyone know this
word
I'm not gonna try that's not that's no
good the um uh and one thing I'm
noticing is we have some extra
um text at the ends of these there's a
function string squash I think it is
that's going to remove the squash I
think that's going to be removing the um
the extra uh colors so I'm going to the
extra white space color equals strings
did I get it right squish uh on color
here we go that removes the extra white
space uh at the end of the beginning of
a string so I can count that it can also
count color hex what I want with the
color and the hex and the graphs because
I might want to make a plot out of this
I'm going to say let's say the number of
paintings compared to the color and we
do a bar plot
and that's it so already saying okay
here's the color here's the N not much
of a not much of a plot until I say I
want to let's see let's make it a little
bit better and order it in descending
order let's do the really the more
interesting we can do which is to
remember
um yes the way uh what I want to do is
give each of these the color that it
actually is I want this to be white I
want this to be for a number I want us
all to find out what the follow green is
I think the way we do that is we do fill
I meaning identity on color hex this
works yes that's the one so I is in a um
uh I is a
built database solid it notifies like I
want this literal thing that's the way
that ggplot understands I don't mean I
want a legend of each color is this
thing I want yeah it should be the color
so man look at just looking at that
doesn't it kind of look like I don't
know it kind of looks like a landscape I
think we're looking at it we're seeing
like a um uh
oh we're kind of seeing this like oh
yeah there's a lot of darks there's um
some lighter colors uh but yeah the um
mostly use the Reds use like bright red
burnt upper a little bit of uh one paint
use this book called uh Indian red uh or
Crimson yeah so um uh so we're kind of
seeing this like uh already a bit of
this story let's make this a little bit
um I like this plot so I'm gonna uh say
number of paintings
I don't think uh
what colors I like the title plots by
the by the question answer did Bob Ross
use the most
here we go
um all right any idea anything else
folks want to do with this plot
anything bothering people about it
things want to change
he can't see the white I wonder how can
we give it an outline I think what I can
do is I can say color I've got color but
I can say color equals black fill equals
that didn't work I oh yeah I gotta say I
black just like I use for the color hex
I can say give each of these an outline
that's too thick uh let's try gray I'm
not completely crazy about that either
we could also try using a uh
background yeah I'm not I'm I'm not
crazy about this approach so let's try
using I can use themed gray the built-in
digipot 2 theme you know I'm less crazy
about the ggplot2 theme uh default like
gray theme in general but it might work
better in this case
as you kind of see in the background
can we get rid of the grid
yeah I like it let's do uh let's do it
so we do theme uh let's see it's um uh
so we've been doing this in my it's
panel grid
element blank
that's the one we can get rid of um we
also might want to get rid of this this
bit of gray space in between there
I remember uh does anyone know how to
get rid of this gray space it's been a
long time to say that I did this
I think it's in scale scale yeah so
it'll be scale
um uh wide discrete
but what do we what do we say expand
equals
zero zero
I think four elements of zeros
hi all right let's find Let's find let's
uh see if we can find that out at some
it's ggplot2
move space under ticks the um it's
something about expand I do feel like
that's
see expand 0 0
oh you know maybe I needed to add it to
the um x axis
Ah that's the one I bet we can do all
right
all right so expand zero zero we have it
uh flat gray background I think it's
like it's pretty good all right and now
we can find out the follow green that
doesn't look green at all
all right first plot down what um uh uh
I didn't add any requests on what's the
next graph we're gonna make
next question we want to answer
yeah how about colors over time all
right let's the um uh so let's see so
we've got this table already of Bob Ross
colors uh something I'm noticing is that
we have these numbers oh you know we
have these Seasons we can actually do
count season color color hex and now we
know within each season how much
um
how much uh each color is being used so
we can use season and fill equals eye
color hex chiam uh so there are a couple
of ways we can do this plot so this is
we're looking at the color palette
evolving over time I don't know that the
total is that interesting so I'm going
to want to do it as that I'm trying to
remember is this position is position
ah what is it it's position uh there's
there's a name for this and I can't
remember um remember how to how to get
everything out of a total
it's called a spinogram how do we get
all these out of a total I think I'm
gonna
remember
what I'm trying to do is I want all of
these to be out of it as a total out of
a percentage we can do this in deep
plier that's I guess what I'm going to
do uh divided by n
percent
here we go so now we can see the um as a
bar plot the uh
the way that the colors have been
changing over time you know I think the
whites in between each of these bars are
kind of bugging me so I'm going to
change this to an area plot
now the fun now I don't even know why
this giving a a weird look with like all
the triangles and such
so I think what's happening is that we
have zeros and the Z and it's the zoom
area doesn't handle the zeros all that
well so anyone know how we can fix that
function called complete where I want to
say I want to complete all the
combinations of season and color hex and
I'm going to fill
n and percent with zero uh it won't it
won't help me with the color but that's
okay so what that means is now oh yes
season Zero season one nobody use this
color and now that I've expanded that
out I think
ah we're bet it's better but something's
up with that top uh with that top bar so
first of all I do like this one thing I
like about this idea is that you take
basically if you take all of Bob Ross's
paintings and you stuck them into a
blender and you arrange the Blended
results uh stacked on top of each other
it would look something like this uh I
wouldn't see it
um Trend over time
I think it's going to depend a lot on
what that top what the um black eye kind
of polygons in the top are doing so
let's see if we can we can sort out
what's going on uh there what color
black I bet that's midnight black uh but
the uh
as soon as this happens when you
duplicate data oh does the same color
have different ah okay so problem is
there was at least one color that was
popping up um
multiple times under different uh color
names so that this fixes it all right
let's polish this up
um
season
age of
this isn't really a percentage of colors
used across
paintings it's not percentage of
paintings that it's used and it's it's
out of all the out of the full set of
colors and
scale y continuous labels
percent format
all right
use of color
foreign
it's a little hard to see here on the um
I think it's easier to see on the TV uh
yes definitely easier to see on the TV
uh let me try turning off the lights
just in case it uh it helps for future
plots
ah it's pretty that's pretty good looks
okay with the lights off all right let's
do it um
this way all right what do people seeing
a change of views of Color Bob Ross
I think so maybe yeah when did his
fortune get stolen we could thread a
little dashed line right there yeah it
does look like
less green the uh you're thinking like
this this bar
yeah yeah
is it a screen
this one
okay I get it now all right here I
always call you yeah uh one thing we see
is he switched uh from one like um uh I
don't know what this would be before or
after one umber or whatever it is to it
uh to another I think that's the only
like swap out we can see at least based
on what what is collecting this data set
so launch a portion of black kind of
same same number amount of use of white
maybe a little bit less red near the end
all right
pretty cool
so uh yeah it's uh
ah that is that is really uh
that's really cool well we can then we
can ask is we can test this Theory by
looking at the titles so we don't um the
other Bob Ross data set I looked at
which maybe we can join in had things
like what objects were in the paintings
uh so yeah let's actually we'll pull
that in a minute but first let's take a
look at the painting titles who has uh
analyzed text Data before
guys who's used their tidy text package
before
so title text is um is uh one that um
Julia silgi and I created in uh 2016 and
it's for analyzing data using the um
it's in our package for analyzing data
using uh the tools in the Tidy verse
like deploy energy plot 2. and the way
that it works is we've got our Bob Ross
cleaned uh blah blah tidied we've got
our clean data uh if I just selected
painting and let's say uh season
oops painting title the way that it
works is I say I want to unnest tokens I
want to have instead of um just uh one
row for a library tidy text
instead of one row per painting I want
one row per word so what I say is word
and painting title
what it does is is
um is turn it lowercase but also split
it so it's now one row per word instead
of one row
per um uh
per painting so now I can I can do uh I
can count it and say oh what are the
most common words
used in Bob Ross paintings and we do
have some things like of in ah but
something is cool is it's actually the
most common ones are mountain and winter
now you can start saying things like oh
are the are the the color scheme used in
pain is the word Mountain different the
color schemes using paintings the word
winter
uh we have some words like of in a we
could probably uh get rid of those so
there's a tool for that
um uh we have a table of stop words that
comes with it with the package uh moving
some uh words that are a little less
interesting so I'm going to go ahead and
remove those with an antide and this is
Bob Ross words uh
let's take let's include colors and
color hex let's look at let's do season
and episode
and numb colors
that's basically all all of them all
right so now I can start asking things
like let's see uh let's count uh
let's count uh common words uh but let's
also say instead of counting the word
discount of the words let's ask a
question about the words let's ask a
question like
average colors what are the average
colors you paint colors used in a
painting that contains the word mountain
or the word winter
I don't know if I'll see anything here
11 or 12 or 50 and I also want n is the
number of paintings
ones that use uh so this is interesting
ones that use uh winter have on average
only 7.4 colors compared to ones that
use mountain or lake oh so winter maybe
we use a smaller palette uh let's try a
graph of those top
um man winter is an outlier
let's make this a little more
interesting size is n and
colors used word in painting title you
know I expected this to be a little more
boring than it is but I think winter
Barn I guess being kind of on the the
lower end uh that is somewhat
interesting and Valley using the most
colors uh
that's kind of cool
my next idea is let's look at what the
um let's let's look at the at the colors
let's try let's like show the average
palette for something that contains one
of these words
so you can do that is we take this set
of words
who has seen fct lump I love this
function uh what FCD lump does is take
the less common words that appear in a
column and put them all into an other
category so I can say word and the top
let's say I don't know we'll take 15
words that have um
yeah let's say we have uh 50 uh
50 we'll take the 15 most girls common
ones keep them around and put all the
rest in a uh and lump them into one
category then I group by word uh and the
um oh nope I'm gonna oh then I'm gonna
count word and color
here we go uh oh no color needs to be
unnested
trick is I need one row per here we go
this is the number of paintings
um in that include the word Autumn that
use this color crimson
maybe not surprising that that the word
we already can see like oh yeah the word
Autumn includes a lot of crimson red
yellow uh but we really can't tell much
until we compare it to the other ones so
I'm going to do a group by word
percent is aneurysm n and I'm gonna plot
these
we're gonna say put the let me see the
percent word
here we go
foreign
what am I getting from this
what are the folks getting from this the
uh
that's true white white leads white
leads uh in Winter uh
the uh and uh and not a lot not a lot of
Orange
uh but the um you know what what this is
telling me though the way that I realize
now I'm looking at it I don't want it
this is not the right way to visualize
this uh because orange being like so
small here and so much bigger everywhere
else is kind of hidden the way that
we're visualizing it
I have a different idea
uh my mom my different idea is we let me
see
by word color
what if we fast set
so uh we say facet by word
and then we say the percentage of that
word uh we say let's see percent color
and let's
order
no I don't want nope I want it
fascinated by color not by word
and I want there's a couple more steps
I'm going to need to do here oh um
yeah one is I uh yeah this is not much
of a graph yet but just wait till we're
done with it so free y
and uh let's lump together let's not
lump together the colors uh
let's see
let's do fewer Colors oh those are fewer
words
let's order Within
um
100 within order within each color
go and let's
better
still do a couple more adjustments
usually but the um but the scale X
percentage of
all right normally I do a little bit
more like uh cleaning up in terms of
like the size attacks and things like
this but this is pretty reasonable uh
what are folks seeing
it feels to me like there are some
colors that are pretty standard like
you'd see like Crimson shows up in like
eight percent of that's on the top up
top left Crimson shows up in like eight
percent of everything
uh but the um
uh with maybe a little bit of exception
like winter and waterfall that a little
bit off uh but then you have things like
cadmium yellow where it's used twice as
much and some than others I realized to
make this relative Point kind of land a
bit better I might want to say I'm going
to put the x-axis free
now they're on and let's put let's use
theme Gray
I hit that grid
it's not this week yes
yeah so we can see that now with one
thing this really gets across is like
okay white way more in winter but kind
of standard everywhere else
uh liquid clear liquid clear waterfall
be the top I make some uh sense to me
and then there's um yeah you've got and
then ah there's really a lot of
variation in burnt umber uh much higher
in stream than in in a cabin for uh like
yeah three times higher in in
the streamlined in a cabin I don't know
if I would have expected bird umber to
pop up and streams I guess it's kind of
a rare color overall
oh all right so that's looking by uh
combinations of words and
paintings
all right
any ideas for what we should analyze
next
I've got two ideas one is we could try
let me see we could try something that
puts that actually brings the the actual
image in and the second idea is we can
uh so bring it from that online um uh
those sources the other option we have
is to uh was my tidy Tuesday
is we could bring in
um the the other Bob Ross data set which
doesn't have data about color but
doesn't date about what objects are in
each um are in each episodes we can try
linking objects to Colors who wants to
bring in the bring images into a GG plot
and who wants to join the other day to
set involving objects
haven't got any other ideas
can you clusters
clustering oh based on what's in them
based on colors these colors yes all
right yeah that's true identify outlier
paintings with unusual palettes yeah so
higher for example we can do
hierarchical clustering on the the set
of colors uh who wants to Cluster
all right let's start by doing let's do
some clustering so to Cluster mostly the
uh here we go uh we've got
Bob let's we've got words we've got
colors
uh
uh when we uh when we cluster what we're
mostly looking at is let's see uh let's
Bob Ross colors
select let's do painting
title season
episode and uh color and color hex
uh what we're going to thinking of is um
is a matrix we're looking at data that's
going to look a little more like this
there's actually a
this is an old school package let me say
uh let's have a painting painting title
uh by color
this is the kind of Matrix we would
usually use if we want to represent Dom
data as we say now we have okay here is
uh Cold Spring day copper winner mild
Winter's day perfect winter day and we
um and then we have here's this Matrix
of of uh ones and zeros we actually had
something a little bit similar in the
original data uh you know I think we
actually can use that now that I think
of it let's take our Bob our original
Bob Ross data
pick all the all the um the columns from
uh black guess so through
uh where's what's the last one uh
Alexander Crimson no it's the the yeah
I think that's about right is that are
there 18
there are 18. so this is the data that's
represented instead of us so right now
this is a table I do as I don't like I
don't like this version because then I
have to give it real names and stuff all
right we're going to use this um
uh we're gonna use this approach we're
gonna say all right
because it has one if they use the color
and zero if um if they didn't so there's
a lot of classic uh approaches we can
take for um for finding correlation uh
you can say like what are the colors are
correlated or what paintings are
correlated so let's start by asking what
are correlated colors uh sentence that's
really um uh useful for this is a
package called um ydr uh I didn't re uh
create all the packets we used today but
I did create this one and it what it
it's about is um finding correlations uh
basically widening this data set so it's
uh right now it's one row per color and
painting finding a correlation among the
paintings or finding a correlation among
the colors so the reason that that's
useful
is that I might take my colors and say
uh what are the pairwise correlation
between a um uh between two colors
appearing based on in the same
painting
well this will say is um is uh if a
painting contains one of these colors
does it contain the other one would mean
they always appear together negative one
would mean they never appear together
zero would mean if the um uh means uh
it's independent of each other if one
appears versus the other so I could see
things like okay bright red and Crimson
appear together more than you expect by
chance based on a correlation to 0.22
we see some like dark Sienna and
midnight black are really strongly
correlated I'm going to plot this as a
let's see um item one item two there's a
word for this it's a
I guess a heat map where was uh and
we'll say correlation
tile I don't like this uh scale uh fill
gradient to always
not low is blue high is red
zero
this is
not that helpful but this uh what this
is showing is like um is uh here we go
uh been a while today I did heat Maps uh
but I think I know how we're gonna how
we're gonna Salvage this the um
uh one is the X on the text
one as you rotate this the challenge
with this is that it's not um so is this
not sorted really we want these to be
clustered together there is a really
um there are a couple of uh these one of
the few things that use built-in are
tools for where we actually can take
instead of of
um working from uh tidy data we take
this Matrix
see it's been a while since I did this
uh we take a correlation of the Matrix
and heat map built-in heat map function
on the correlation of the Matrix there
we go now the um here the the colors are
the yellow and red don't actually
represent yellow and red or some of them
do we can say uh this would say like
okay what are the clusters of um uh that
tend to appear together and you can see
okay uh midnight black and dark Sienna
appear together and then you've got
you've got some block then you've got a
block up there of yellow Indian yellow
bright red cadmium yellow sap green that
uh the tender appear together you can
kind of see three maybe three blocks or
something like that or I guess two
blocks top level of colors but I'm not
getting as much out of it but I think
what might be interesting is we try core
instead we tried correlating paintings
there are 400 paintings it's going to
look I think less than perfect but let's
take a look what we can get here we go
see four that does not look like 400
paint oh it's not 400 paintings that
only show us
it'll only show us a portion so back
when I worked in biology PhD in biology
and we we did a lot of things with heat
Maps like this this is um what is doing
is it'll cluster your uh it'll cut it
it'll cluster about the rows and cluster
The Columns uh and since we try and look
for like oh yeah here's a block of
colors that go together
um
but what uh what we're seeing here at
one thing that I'm seeing here
is that let's actually let's sample that
so let's say I'm going to take only
let's do 50 paintings
are these are the first 50
alphabetically which is a little uh
corny so I'm going to do
random sample of 50. uh
what do I do wrong
Mr Karma
what we're trying out here is clustering
50 paintings based on the colors used
the most interesting bit here is this
trees this is called the dendrogram and
it's about cluster excuse me clustering
similar color profiles together so you
can see here for example is there's um
there's two up here at the top it's
funny because it look looks like let me
see can I can I zoom out is going to
show anymore
ah there it is yeah there are the two
paintings County Creek and Valley View
that use the exact it's very hard to
read this we're just I know County Creek
and Valley View use the same
um uh use the exact same color palette
and then there's other ones that use uh
similar color palettes where here um the
red in this case the red just means a
color was used in the um uh yellow means
it wasn't uh so the um so here
we're looking at yeah uh
I think we can do this uh but yeah this
is looking at like clusters of paintings
together it's a little hard to get uh
something out of this seem like
prizing Falls and gray Mountain things
you're saying I'm going to try one other
approach to clustering
which is this
I would be trying out these built-in
functions I haven't used in a while
here we go oh boy so this is
plus oh boy this is this is impossible
to read
a little better
okay we did here was was take a hundred
random uh paintings and cluster them and
one thing we can see is okay there's
actually a whole block of ones here
that a lot of them have the word
Mountain there's uh yeah mountain and
oval mountain river
peaceful Reflections purple mountain
range uh so there's a block that used
similar colors I guess we had to say
there's maybe two clusters of Bob Ross
paintings we'd have like this this batch
and then this batch I'm not getting just
from look glancing at them I'm not
necessarily getting like oh yeah this is
the um these are the uh the the
two different types of paintings
that's what I'm gonna uh that's what I'm
getting for now yeah
hmm
I don't have other ideas for things they
want ways they want to look at this
who's used principal component now
can we do a network analysis of colors
used together per season see how it
changes over time oh man I don't know
since correlations over time that's
pretty brutal that's pretty esoteric but
Network oh all right
oh okay let's I've got two ideas for for
things one is um let's try showing this
network a bit differently uh show it as
here we go
instead of as a heat map let's show it
as a network who has made Network plots
because you said network analysis who's
made Network plots in R before
great tool for oh I zoom back in for
everyone
great tool for this is
um is ggraf uh which is um for uh
networks using uh the grammar of
Graphics like digiplot the beautiful
thing about ggraf is uh
let's see
is I let's see if I can remember how to
use this it has been a while
yes all right
correlation greater than 0.1
all right
all right the great thing about gdrf is
that we can say is that it can feed from
directly from a tidy analysis into
making a network plot so for example I
say all right I want
um I want to do Edge link
um
uh
uh there you go uh Jam mode
and I want a different layout
here we go this is a way of looking at
at clusters of um so there's a way of
looking at clusters of colors uh it
looks a little bit better than heat Maps
the way they work is it says the
correlation the um the links between
these are correlation and I can even say
ASL uh
Alpha equals correlation
uh so the stronger and weaker ones and
this lets us say the um okay the uh
clusters of colors that tend to appear
together using ggraph but I think it's
going to be a little more interesting if
we try doing it on the paintings instead
of on the colors
paint uh
foreign
that is
one way to show it let's see the uh well
let me do one more thing the uh
um
all right then what this does is show
actually oh that that makes it a lot
clearer actually if you look at it this
way this is um any pair of each point
represents one painting and then the um
uh it's connected to the ones that that
uh use a similar color scheme uh so one
thing that I'm going to see from this is
that the top one there's a cluster that
use exactly the same color up there
Mount McKinley and quite extreme stream
and mountain lake and there's this one
that uses uh uh then there's yeah
there's this cluster where there's like
one that and then a lot of ones that are
very similar to it even if they aren't
necessarily quite as similar to each
other uh so we saw from the color
profiles that there were a lot of things
that had extremely similar colors so
it's not surprising that there's a lot
of things that uh uh here that are like
partly correlated together yeah there's
one we could we can try and draw circles
around clusters
the other deal was an animation do you
want to see an animation and then we uh
then you know we I started at 6 10 so I
usually like to go for one hour does
that work for you
still need to do PCA too I do need I I
can do PCI who wants to well let's ask
who wants to see an animation
nobody said nobody's in animation who
wants the principal component analysis
oh awesome all right let's see the let's
do uh principal component analysis so
who's used principal component analysis
before
physical mode analysis is find is uh
about finding um it's a little like
cluster analysis but it's about fuzzy
clusters it's about what are the
underlying drivers of variation in the
data like maybe there's um there's lots
of variation but mostly it fits into
into one spectrum of maybe more wintry
and more summery uh so the um so
physical component announce is a
mathematical tool for pulling out those
sources of variation and the um the
package the uh uh ydr package provides a
way to to do it on this color this tidy
color data set but we do it is let's see
Pam
called widely SVD and remember now we do
the item will be the painting the uh
feature is the color
and the let me see oh uh
pinning title
painting title color
painting title
color and the uh oh the value would have
to be
always one gotcha so with um what this
does here we go is uh let's actually do
it the other way around let's do
principal component Mouse on the colors
what are the underlying um
yes so
this would say something like
you ever hear of uh folks maybe the
social sciences or a magazine say there
are two types of people or people fall
along a spectrum
um is that saying uh a lot of those are
built on analysis like like this or
factor analysis which is closely related
which says like um if you take a look
you could take lots and lots of traits
and you you narrow them down to there's
one underlying correlated trait that is
driving uh that is driving this
variation we can see something like it
here where if we um and this is this is
here what I'm uh what we're finding is
ah this if I say what is the top biggest
source of variation like what these
colors tender tender either you do use a
lot on this side of spectrum or a lot on
this side of the spectrum
first principal component that is the
one driving the largest amount of
variation would be
let me clean this up
all right would be usually so there's a
trick here which is that usually the the
biggest source of variation in these is
which one is the most common and we do
know Indian red is the uh the least
common so there's like there's one
source of variation that is a lot of uh
paintings used titanium white and each
of these other ones let's bring in the
second
let's look at the second
Dimension yeah this I think is a little
bit cleaner as they are all right so
this is this what this is saying is the
biggest source of variation among
paintings is some use a lot of bird
Dumber follow whatever green sap green
let me speak of which let's not try to
remember what these colors look like
let's say fill is color hex which I will
need to join I don't have the color hex
but I can get it
with a join I do
distinct color color hex
there we go uh this value doesn't have a
real scale it's not like oh uh you know
0.5 paintings or anything like that but
it's saying there's paintings that use a
lot of
Sienna black
clear
um then and uh and black and then
there's paintings that use a lot of bird
number green oh you can kind of see it
it's kind of like rainbow like variety
of rainbow colors versus uh kind of just
just black and and darker colors so this
is the the biggest source of variation
across these um uh
across these paintings I can look at the
top four of these go if I fast it
by the dimension
go and I might wanna
um
foreign
so this is saying is that the um uh if
we brought that broke down paintings
into it just a couple of of numbers to
describe them to be one of how much uh
burnt dumber and green and yellow do you
use versus dark Sienna midnight black
and there's sort of another dimension
here that I would describe as like
that's kind of a kind of similar it's
like light to dark but now um
yeah it's like and then now Indian
yellow and yellow ocher are the ones
that are dry that are driving it uh
versus Prussian Blue is the extreme on
the other side and then there's kind of
one more Dimension that's black versus
Blue uh so this brings it the the
um paintings down into just a few
dimensions
um who write it raise your hand if
you've done principal component analysis
before
oh awesome yeah so for um those who
haven't I know this is kind of like do
we know there should be a whole like
weak in a statistics class which is
we're compressing it down to uh my hand
wavy uh
you know I'm a half remembered
explanation from grad school but the uh
the other way that we uh one way we
could say how many principal components
should we use we're representing this
data how many are driving variation a
way to tell that
is odd can I
go widely I got my widely SVD
I don't know I um I
will have to do it on the Matrix itself
because I can't quite do I can't quite
do with widely SVD that's okay I'll do
it's a validity composition on The
Matrix
there's a trick to this
that's the one
so the um this is percent of variance
explained by each um
principal component turns out the first
one which is kind of the most boring one
of just how many colors are being used
is the thing that's uh driving most the
variation but if you uh if you ignore
this so that that's never the most
exciting uh result you can you can get
uh
but we kind of see up to Dimension five
what do you usually do with this is you
look for whereas a break point the first
cut the next couple Dimensions each are
somewhat are relevant uh reason this is
interesting is we can um
uh yeah that's a bit of a expression
that all right uh
so the last thing we can do is ask for
let's say we've got the second principle
component we've got the SEC this one
where we're saying something like
where was I uh
we were saying that the second color
yeah the second color of umber versus of
like kind of blue and green and umber
versus just black and Sienna that that
seems to drive a solid amount of
variation we could flip this around
where instead of saying here we go
instead of plotting of uh by painting we
look at the same principal components if
we flip it and we say what are the
paintings that best most describe each
of these dimensions
the way that I do that is look at the
top
uh 20
paintings in each
Dimension what we say I'll write a
H that's not an interesting analysis oh
well the um the story this usually can
say is something like
here are the one here are the ones that
are most extreme in One Direction versus
the other I'm not quite getting that
here I don't know
I don't know the privilege this is
binary data and binary data doesn't
always uh did do that well under PCA but
all right we saw an example it's improv
it doesn't always work out
so uh let's we'll go through everything
that we that we uh did today so we uh
started with the um we took we had this
uh table of um uh of all the of colors
we saw that the one of the columns
colors was uh was compressed together
where we say something like the um uh
with the brackets and quotes and such so
we tidied those turned that into a list
column uh tidied it so we could actually
answer questions like here the most
common colors and built our first plot
out of that then we looked at we um
broke apart the uh where's my where's my
one of of change over time where's my
one of a change over time
there it is
um so we uh said then we said okay how
is it changing we saw okay Bob Ross
might not have a blue period but he just
did change around season eight to use
some more black he switched from one
type of um rather to uh to another uh
and um uh kind of consistent use to
things like white then we started
comparing it to things with um like what
words were uh were used so the uh
we said we are
nope uh we looked at
yeah we used High text to break apart
the words in each so we could get one
row per word now let's answer something
like for each of these words what's the
average number of colors that are used
we see okay winter tends to use fewer
colors we Valley and waterfall use use
uh the most and then we broke out to
what what specific colors are used in
each of these um uh in each of these
paintings we tried it out with like a
stack in the palette and we tried it out
another one where we said here we go the
um
what uh these are the words that uh some
we notice that some words
show a lot of very a lot of variations
some very little like there's some
colors that are kind of standard or
equally common uh and others that uh
where it depends a lot on what the
subject of the painting is about
so then we did a little bit of um of uh
clustering and network analysis where we
start where we said go
nope not here
where is my cluster
where we try we created some um uh
clusters and heat Maps where we said
okay here's the um uh the uh the ways
that the the class of paintings that
look um that look similar we looked at
um
there we go um and then we did principal
component analysis where we tried saying
uh what are the dimensions that drive
the most variation on like the the uh
Dimensions or pallets that that uh that
show the um uh the the dry variation
across how uh what colors are chosen in
paintings
all right uh
any questions anything we did today
first I'm excited yeah excited to have
your life
[Applause]
folks yeah quite a chance to uh SDR have
any questions about what he did
which of these packages he wrote versus
others uh ask ask away
but I'm happy to do that at the bar show
or whatever
yeah oh well I'm not mic'd up yet but so
I don't think let me uh let's see if
there's any questions here ah okay there
are some questions here let me
just
I can't tell by just feeling it how many
people are on the live stream
like 40. yeah I think I think my mic is
up again all right let's see
um
what was the name of the color that does
not say anything about his coverage on
the canvas huh
what's the name of that
mention the name of the color oh okay
yeah no it uh it would be cool I think
what it's saying is a color could be
mentioned but only used in one little
dot or in a large part of the canvas
yeah that would have been cool I think
to show like how much of the painting
was it used uh that would be a cool data
set
oh you know we could have done we could
have downloaded the images and found out
that would have been neat maybe next
time like a mosaic of images in sept
October come back and do the Mosaic of
images slam nice yes
first what's that
yes sure that's true
what because every color is a mixture of
the certain primary colors so you could
figure out
instead of doing the color now
break that down by primary color red
yeah
oh that would be that would be really
cool like I have no idea how we go about
going for do it like going from a hex to
uh to a painting isn't that how you do
it but I I know you could do it you saw
that Ted Talk video
I didn't see any
they can do with RGB so the um uh like
these represent three hexadecimal
numbers uh so this one for example has
uh which which color is uh
it's like uh let's do uh you can just
look at the first of each pair like four
one yes you so like um so that's a
that's a good call it's like is so here
Crimson this one has uh four e and hex
is a a lot of red as we expect
um
some green no blue our G RGB I think is
right yeah uh and then black has no has
no colors at all bright red has only red
and um and so on so we could that's a
good yeah but mine decided but you can
use um color hex color as a function is
a great function for this called extract
where you say uh from color hex I want
the columns uh red green and blue and
you give it a pattern
a regex pattern of
this
Dot Dot and now we've split it out into
like red to green and blue then another
step to get turn that into those numeric
yeah sorry the thing you were saying
about the PCA
um you said that it I just wanted to ask
more about you said that usually like a
little trick is that usually one of the
more driving underlying correlations is
the thing that's most commonly used yes
you can
um
so we uh
like maybe a different example that's
not with colors I've heard of PCA but I
hadn't heard that part yeah there's a
way to fix it which is you Center the
rows first but it's um so it's been a
while to use this like uh professionally
not just for uh fun I think oh yeah so
so the um so through this uh
if we had a data set with something like
populations
it's not a good uh
it's not I I don't have a great example
let me uh I mean I guess
I guess white was the most frequently
used thing so in this thing so you were
were you saying that maybe you would
expect that the amount of white being
used would most likely Drive the
variation in the other color being used
it's more that the the goal of of these
is to is to um yeah so the goal is is
say you add some amount of this first
principal component and some amount to
the second and some amount to this third
together and it gets something very
close to the to the actual combinations
and you want to be able to approximate
the overall
um the the distribution the paintings as
close as you can just with a couple of
those principal components so the for um
if the first one is just you take the um
the average frequencies of each of them
that's already a pretty good get that's
that's kind of like where you'd want to
start is you start from everything has
the average and then you move around
from there
it's kind of the way to think about it
I'm not the best at explaining this the
other part though yeah
yeah oh yeah
but then how it's possible for one
painting to be similar to a lot of them
but none of those to be similar to the
other ones in that cluster sure I think
that what was the question yes so the
question is in a network graph how can
um one painting be a lot of paintings be
similar to one but then they're not
similar to each other so I think
actually the main reason for that was
just that there's I think there's a lot
of ties here so here we go
was this the graph that I had let's see
yes so I think what happened
imagine it is oh yeah all that happened
is all of these are exactly the same so
it um it didn't uh
I should have just said filter
correlation is one
and there are thousands of pairs of
paintings with a correlation of one
that's kind of the challenge when you're
working just from 18 pieces of data yeah
this is what if uh yeah so that was all
that was happening was somewhere being
included by chance and some weren't uh
thanks for calling me out on that uh we
have some like these here that the links
represent only correlations that are
exactly so the paintings that are
exactly the same this is where a lot of
paintings that use the same combination
combination of colors
hmm
I don't have a lot of familiarity with
clusters I've never seen that before but
I'm just wondering if because it's we
have so much but they are similar I
wonder if we would it help to categorize
you know words and looking at the amount
of colors so through the words into like
land words or whatever words season
words would we see more correlation or
do you not want to do that do you want
you want it all at that granular level
to see this
I think it's a great question the
question is could you also categorize
um could you categorize words look at
their correlation
um so definitely I think there are a few
ways you you could approach this it
depends on what you're trying to explore
if we were fitting a machine learning
model let's say we had uh oh this has
been a fun data set to grab is IMDB
ratings of each of the episodes and we
want to predict how popular this episode
going to be we might treat each word as
a feature and each color as a feature
maybe and uh maybe discover oh uh ones
including burnt Dumber are really
popular but one's including the word
Mountain are less popular
um but then uh uh often when you have
hundreds and hundreds of these features
you want to do Dimension uh you find a
lot of them are redundant and a lot of
them are very sparse so two different
problems you can run and do one is like
is as we saw like some of these colors
maybe are really used together a lot but
we don't need both of them some words
are sparse maybe this word um uh so the
word Falls might have appeared a lot
probably the word twin uh might have
appeared only once or very rarely so
then you want then you might want to um
to Bunch them together and do um uh uh
and then like do and uh yeah group them
by something like topic so there are a
lot of methods for doing that and um but
both of those are our attempts to solve
as is PCA saw the problem we call
dimensionality reduction taking uh
dimensionality reduction what we're
doing with those 18 colors we are taking
an 18 dimensional data set turning into
more like a four dimensional data set or
we could do we could have done the same
to words as well we could have said here
the um the words they tend to appear
together
that would make quality to do is combine
words and and colors and then do PCA
there uh yeah I think that would have
been a little more all right
there's a virtual question and then
we'll do some giveaways and we'll get
some more questions
um would anyone say that pivot wider and
I'm not Mike's here to repeat this but
anyone say that pivot wider and pivot
longer functions and tidier may have
some the same functionality of reshape
cast oh yeah so the question is to Pivot
longer and pivot wider in tidier have
some of the same functionality as
reshapes cast yes so this is so we're
actually looking at three generos is it
a uh grade like however's history
question there are three generations of
this kind of operation at least three
generations of this operation of
um I have a if I have data in one shape
and I want to put it I want to make it
wider I want to make it longer if we're
looking just so first actually was
the reshape package uh which um which I
think might have been deprecated a long
time ago because then there was reshape
two it should have been popular around I
think like 2010 to 2012 that don't quote
me on that uh which um included
functions like a cast and D cast so D
and those are all about take something
that's long and make it uh and make it
wider or or
um reverse so first there was uh
we probably would have done this kind of
Step of like take your Bob Ross colors
and do
um uh let's see what what is painting
Title by color
so dcast would have been one what used
to be how we would we would do a step
like that uh stuff like this later it
was replaced by tidyar's spread
which would have done Bob Ross colors
and then it would set up painting
uh
um would have just said color and value
and you would have needed a value column
and then that was and that was uh so so
then people recommend you spread over
dcast and then spread was replaced by
pivot
wider uh so these I think are different
generations of the um of uh solving a
similar problem and I'll buy the same
author these all created by um Hadley
Wickham the big difference between the
uh the reason I simply still go to
reshape 2 is a function called a cast
which casts to a matrix a is a reference
to array uh it's still it's still a
little iffy to tidyar and uh really is
meant to work with tibbles not with
matrices so that's why I still sometimes
plot a cast
if there's any other questions in this
room
I'll translate questions virtually and
then we'll go to the bar
so we only have time for two so it'll be
more than two we're not doing you got to
ask them at the bar and it's one beer
per question
or whiskey
all right then virtual okay virtually
says can you recreate one of the GG plot
graphs using lattice no no one asked
that that was for me yeah yeah that
would be yeah of course all right so
with that I guess
um thank everyone for coming here in
person thank you everyone for being here
virtually August we will announce
sometime after the conference September
we'll announce after August October
November December we need both space and
we need a speaker
and
just uh join the slack post your jobs on
there and hopefully I'll see a bunch of
you in the next coming months I remember
discount code for all the events go to
nyhacker.org to find past talks
um we have a decade of talks up there
um the code and my hack are for any
event we put on get 20 off and yeah just
have one up see you next month we'll see
you next week thank you to D Rob
everybody
[Applause]